welcome everyone to
our next episode of dc thursday i'm pete
soderling
i'm the founder of data council and the
data community fund
and i'm happy to be here shepherding you
through
the craziest sprawling immense vast data
ecosystem
and thank you for those of you who have
been following us for all these months
through the pandemic uh we're getting
excited to come back to live events in
person sometime soon so
uh stay tuned for announcements there
but in the meantime we're
happy to be continuing uh to stay online
and digital
and uh and we're glad that you're able
to join us today so
i'm extremely excited to announce our
guest
today and introduce him it's nick
schrock who's the founder
and ceo of elemental and elemental is
the company behind
the dagster open source project
formerly nick was a software engineer at
facebook and microsoft
and he's perhaps best known for being
the original
co-creator of graphql
so nick thanks for joining us today
thanks for having me pete
so um nick you've uh
spent a lot of time in developer tooling
and um the folks in our community
know you through your work on dexter as
of the last few years
but before that i just want to you know
sort of catch folks up
on some of your background and
how you got into the data world in the
first place um
i know that at facebook obviously we're
involved in the graphql
language and um and designing that i was
curious
um how did you move from sort of the
graphql
um domain into the into the modern data
domain
how did that happen yeah it's a great
question pete because i actually didn't
you know graphql and related
technologies that i worked on at
at facebook were targeted towards
application developers people people
building web apps and
mobile apps specifically in consumer
apps and
i left facebook 2017 and was figuring
out what to do next
and i was talking to
legacy uh well not legacy software
companies and also
companies that do software which means
every company and
you know i originally was like exploring
avenues like healthcare
and kind of other places that i thought
would be interesting for
um uh interesting to kind of
see what would happen to adopt modern
technologies and i kept on asking them
what their biggest
technical liabilities were and this
notion of data infrastructure and ml
infrastructure
came up over and over again and then i
was like huh that's interesting
i wonder what all the companies around
stoma
and in the valley say and i started
talking to them and lo and behold the
same thing
kept on coming out over and over again
that data infrastructure was just this
enormous technical liability and a huge
source of productivity
issues and a really you know a huge
barrier to making progress in their
various businesses
and you know when i i'm just
so compelled to work on
developer productivity and serving
engineers that
when i kind of hear about or see that
sort of developer experience dumpster
fire i'm just like drawn
to it like i'm austin england and
you know upon investigation i discovered
what you know i like to call it the
biggest
gap between the complexity and
criticality of a problem domain
and the tools and processes to support
that domain that i've ever seen
in my career that was certainly true in
kind of 2017-2018
and yeah i think a lot of other people
recognize that too why there's so much
activity in the space
um but you know and it's
it's actually a deceptively uh
complicated and sophisticated domain as
well
so i just kind of got into it and
started looking into it and i was hooked
and i
was really compelled to work on this
problem space
yeah the complexity sucked you in um and
and
and before that i think many people
might not know that
um you you were also involved in
developer tooling and
um infrastructure type stuff even before
facebook and graphql
um you know how did those experiences
shape your career
yeah i've always been super interested
in it you know i worked
for a year at microsoft uh
in the developer division and
you know i was actually you know i i
didn't really
you know to be fully honest like i
didn't really accomplish that much in
that year and i actually went to
the london school of economics after
that and i thought about not doing
software
but i still like loved developer tools
back then and
the developer division had incredibly
talented engineers um
and i really looked up to especially
like the c-sharp team and really liked
the way they approached things
and that was definitely an early
influence and then you know what i found
is that i kept
on you know i got back from software i
worked for a healthcare startup and then
i kind of
for a little bit tried to start a uh
finance fintech startup as well
and while i was working on those
problems i kept on attempting to do
product and failing because
i would start building the product and
something about the way that the system
was structure would like so
kind of offend my sense of trades
craftsmanship that would be sucked into
building infrastructure
uh because i would see my colleagues
like doing all this repetitive work
and uh you know wasting their time and
whatnot and that just drives me
crazy so i always kind of ended up
supporting no matter what i tried i
would always end up
supporting the other developers around
me and trying to
like make them more leveraged as opposed
to working on the product directly and
that pattern followed facebook too i
kind of initially worked on
was working on product at facebook and
then hopped down
one layer of the stack and formed a team
called product infrastructure so it's a
kind of repeated pattern throughout my
career
got it and um and back to the facebook
since you mentioned it um there was sort
of a parallel
work or or some uh support between
the graphql team and the react team i
think i've heard you
mention this before so somehow you were
involved
um at least tangentially in both can you
explain that
yeah i you know i didn't work on react
directly but
it was a team we were highly affirmed
with meaning like they
we could you know we sat close enough
where we could each
you know hear each other talk and
whatnot so we were
highly fine teams and then
philosophically the
the systems were very similar and then
they would have uh you know i was really
passionate
especially for react native and you know
they would um you know i would help
evangelize it on their behalf a little
bit
about it but you know the the team com
those two teams came from the same dna i
would say in terms of their approach and
i think any user who uses both graphql
and react at the same time can kind of
see the
the like the similar taste aesthetic and
some of the underlying design principles
got it so so then um stepping out of
facebook you decided to get into the
data world
um what was your perception of the state
of the union
of data tooling due to infrastructure
when you
decided to attack this problem
so it reminded me of web
development in the late 2000s
both in terms of technical properties as
well as cultural properties
so what i mean by that is that
you know if you're if you're a developer
in early in 2010
and you're working in like a
non-javascript normal code base
the moment that you hop in to a
javascript code base in that era
you almost like regress as a developer
like there's guaranteed video tests your
development flow is totally broken
you're just fighting the browsers
constantly the frameworks are developed
like all your tools disappear and
therefore it's almost like
you're kind of traveling back in time
and then people
didn't want to work in that domain they
uh they would kind of like just do as
little possible
do do as little as possible in those
code bases and get out
and they would say they were spending
all their time fighting the browser
and you know i think the data domain
was in a is in a similar spot still
and there's both cultural and technical
artifacts around all that
so a cultural like property
is there's a lot of like
self-deprecation
around like oh i'm just a data gender
i'm a cleaner
and then you go to a data science
conference and they say like i spend 90
of my time data cleaning um which
would seem like a big problem if you
think that
and the implication is that that 90 is
not part of their job
um and that just like echoes
from that that previous um
kind of analogy and then you know if you
take
it's it's a similar thing you take and
you take a developer
who works in one domain and they write
tests and they have a nice developer
workflow using all these tools
then you plop them in data the
constraints are different the tools are
different and kind of everything
grinds to a halt a bit like people are
much more fearful of changing things
there's not as fast developer life cycle
um you know it's just it's just
extremely challenging
and you know that's kind of the
perception
that i have i think things are getting
incrementally better on that front
um in terms of developer experience but
there's still like
so much so far to go you know
and in fact you know the there's so many
tools being added to the ecosystem now
that's almost like
increasing the problem in a way it's
like incredibly confusing
uh in terms of what tool sets they
should be using and whatnot so i think
it's still
there's a lot of people doing a lot of
good work in this front
but it's still in quite a a difficult
spot for a data practitioner
making their way in the world
so you're you know so you're not only an
engineer
you're a builder of tooling for
engineers
um you know you have a bunch of
experience doing that and at least one
um successful project under your belt
you're looking at this morass of the
data ecosystem
um how do you start to figure out
where's the right place for nick to work
like what like what what what sort of
the mental model that you use
um to figure out you know where you're
gonna jump in
and to have the most value yeah
i typically start from the developer
experience
standpoint meaning understanding what
people are doing what their goals are
and then how they achieve that goal kind
of in a tactical sense like literally
watch them on a keyboard
um that's generally the starting that's
generally the starting spot
for this because you start somewhere and
i consider that
that is like the leverage point of like
understanding
precisely at a tactical level what
developer experience you're fixing
and then from there if you come up with
a developer better developer experience
that imposes the
the the correct level of constraints
and with the right level flexibility on
that developer but you
but then you can use that new
abstraction layer to like
increase organization
to operate within the system or even
improve and improve the technical
qualities of what's going on
so i usually start you know start at the
developer experience
use that as a wedge to kind of expand
the architectural space and the way even
the organizations operate
and think of it kind of in
multi-dimensional terms like that so
that's
typically where i start in the case of
in data what i noted
was that there is a single core activity
that nearly every data practitioner does
and that is they build graphs of
computations that consume and produce
data assets
whether you're an etl developer
a data engineer a data scientist
an ml engineer at the end of the day
that is what you're doing
you are writing these graphs that ingest
some piece of data
do some compute and then produce
something else whether it's a file a
table
a machine learning model but it's
fundamentally all the same activity
um and i thought the developer
experience around that most
core of activities in data was
fundamentally broken
is uh what i identified
and did you sort of see this as a
quote orchestration problem at the time
or
i mean i think today if i'm not mistaken
and you'll tell us more about daxter i
think you would call
dexter a data orchestrate that correct
that's correct so initially i didn't
view it
as an orchestration problem because
orchestration is one uh one aspect of it
meaning like that's what happens when
you deploy these computations to
production
like you are orchestrating the data
around um
you know to me the the initial framework
was not orchestration
um but just instead like the api and the
programming model
in a more kind of purist way um
you know that you should be able to
write these graphs as computations a
simple python functions
and have a really nice developer
experience around it now it turns out in
order to accomplish our objectives we
need to vertically integrate more
and have uh control more of the
infrastructure in the deployed
compute environment and and also
we need to go where the users were in
terms of terminology
what like yeah and when they're
approaching
a system like dagster they think of it
in terms of either workflow management
or orchestration
and you know you need to use familiar
terms that
uh folks can grapple with but you know i
think
dagster really views orchestration as
as a a broader it should have a broader
purview
in the data ecosystem because um
you know it should be the subject of a
full development life cycle on a well
thought out programming model and not
just a way to kind of order
scripts in production so that's kind of
the evolution of how we came
started from there and got to the
description of the data orchestrator
got it well i'm almost reticent to ask
you
um what could be a bit of a remedial
question because you're so well known
in the data council community and i
think i'm assuming that
many folks watching today are already
familiar with dexter but
um before we go further why don't you
take the floor
and just tell us what the extra is um
so that's so that we have sort of a
common language um for everyone
forward totally so dagster is a
open source python framework so you can
pip install it and the goal you're
trying to accomplish when you
when you're writing dexter is you're
you're writing
graphs or dags of computation dag
meaning directed a circle graph
um you know if you're
for most technical audiences who aren't
familiar with that term
i often analogize it to a factory
where you know whenever you're putting
data products into production you're
generally actually assembling an
assembly line
um either run by one or or
well it's been built actually by
multiple people so
the data engineer builds a machine which
takes data
ingests it and then and then spits it
out
that goes to the data scientist that
then has a different machine that
adjusts that
and spits it out and effectively you
know the orchestrator
is the thing that you know is the
blueprint for the factory so to speak
so the the practitioners build that
machine
the orchestrator orders those
computations and allows you to like stop
the assembly line and restart it
and what so that's kind of like in the
high level abstract
the problem that uh dexter is trying to
solve is kind of
you know a bunch of people are coming
together to build this data factory
and you need kind of a structure and a
way to interconnect the components
and operate the factory in a uniform way
while supporting a bunch the fact that
lots of different people are coming to
the table with their own tooling to do
their job
um so that is the
kind of the analogy version of what
we're trying to solve for the
engineering audience
you know you are writing uh you're
writing dags
um and you are effectively doing data
computations
and doing that in a graph structure and
we just allow you to write plain old
python
and you can write functions with say
like take data frames and produce data
frames
you have a local testable environment
for that and then you can deploy those
computations in production
and order them and then also track the
produce assets so
we really view ourselves as a full life
cycle orchestrator where we really think
about not just the deployed context
but also the dev and test experience
then you deploy execute those
computations and because the
complications are data aware
we track and manage the actual asset
production
uh at the end of the day so you know we
really like to think about
ourselves and and solution for building
for building data-aware dags
with a really smooth dev and test
lifecycle as well
got it um and what are the core
abstractions
that you're working with in dextre
yeah so you know that is um
you know at the basic level the kind of
core abstraction is this pipeline
consists of node of nodes of compute
that we call solids
um but you can think of those as tasks
um we are going to um
look we'll get in bad but we may be
changing some naming around this stuff
fairly soon
um and you know you assemble these
pipelines
out of these solids um and these solids
are data aware
so traditionally tasks in these systems
are not data aware you just have a task
and it's connected with an edge to a
previous task
and there's no notion of data passing in
dagstr you write a function
it's data aware that might that way the
system can handle
you know if each of those uh tasks end
up
operating for instance in different
processes across a cluster
the system will take care of marshalling
that data from one node to another
uh so that's really important that
allows us to do
kind of uh like nice
nice features like being able to
re-execute uh
re-execute computations from where they
left off and
it's just generally really nice for a
developer to be able to think in data
dependencies so they don't have to have
um think of like two things at the same
time meaning like the ordering of
computations and the data dependencies
another really important part of dagster
is that we have an explicit way to model
the operating environment
where you uh are executing and this is
really important
uh if you want to be able to write data
pipelines
that uh can execute in multiple
different places
so for example on your laptop in a cicd
pipeline
and in production so you can for example
write a function which just takes a
pando's data frame framework produces a
data frame
on your laptop you might be passing that
data
between the different processes if
you're doing multi-processing by
persisting it to a file
but then once you deploy it a file in
the file system but once you deploy it
uh to production you might want to be
persisting it
to s3 for example in aws
and what this allows you to do is you
can maximize the amount of code
that you can test in an environment
neutral way
uh meaning that you can have this fast
developer loop
on your uh on your laptop and
and or in a like just a fast developer
loop in general if you need to develop
in the cloud
uh and this is really the first thing
that our users grasp onto where they
just feel this like new level of
empowerment of like oh
like this is the first kind of this is
the first pipelining framework
i've ever used that thinks about the
developer experience
first um and that like is like the first
thing that people
uh notice about it so you know and
a critical component of that is the
structuring of resources
um we also have we believe that dag
should be typed
so we have the ability to type the edges
of dags effectively while the inputs and
outputs and so
and because data is you know
it's very hard to make universal
guarantees about data because
everything's so domain specific and
whatnot we have this very flexible type
system
where it allows you to kind of you know
make arbitrary effective data quality
tests uh associated with edges of dags
to ensure that
yes the data that i'm getting is
actually what i expect
um so we have a basic type checking
system as well
um yeah typically these data
pipelines have a lot of config
they need to manage and often those can
be um
you know big unstructured blobs that are
undocumented
and it's really easy to make errors so
we come with also a
an opt-in schematize config system
so that if you for instance misspell
a key in a dictionary or a yaml
file for some configuration that the
computation requires we can probably
provide
tooling like our auto completing config
editor which is like an ide
almost and then um and also provides
super high quality error messages
rather than like some inscrutable error
that you might catch in production
um sure so that's that's another really
important thing
and then the other kind of core
abstraction which matters a lot
is that our computations produce
an immutable stream of structured data
that describe
what has been happening in the
computation so
you know all other systems i know about
don't have something like that they
capture just raw logs
which is a minimum we also do lot logs
because it's a minimum requirement for
observability and whatnot um but i like
to call logging developers
thinking aloud i mean it's unstructured
people just put whatever they want in
the text
often you end up like very difficult to
sift through
we actually produce this structured log
which you can filter
have specialized display um
which makes it for example instead of
like combing a huge
log file for some stack trace we can
just as you type
find like the error that occurred in a
particular one of a pipeline and
immediately surface like a really well
structured
uh error message so you know it's that
that immutable log is really powerful
both in terms of debugging observability
but it also serves as a system of record
um for all your data computations um and
it's how we build up
um various metadata catalogs that we
have in the system as well
so this structured event log is kind of
a critical thing as well
so so all right so yeah so so
fascinating um there's a couple
questions i want to ask you at this
point um
one is kind of going further down this
this road
that you just um started started on and
and if you don't want to
go down there let me know but um to what
extent
is dexter um going to build the data
catalog
or going to build a data lineage system
or right there's all of these other
um sort of categories of tooling that's
popping up
in the modern data ecosystem and it
seems to me like
um you know based on the way you're
chaining these functions together and
the inputs and the outputs and the
strong types and all these things like
um you know does this become some sort
of data lineage
um system in the future or what what are
your thoughts on that
it is it is a data linear system now um
so you can produce we have a uh
kind of a feature within the system we
call the asset catalog
um which is an integrated what we call
an operational asset catalog
um you know we we envision this working
in concert with systems like amazon and
data hub
which have you know data council
affiliated systems
um but for we think it makes a ton of
sense to
vertically integrate asset awareness
into the orchestrator
and it's incredibly powerful um
so one is that the orchestrator
especially a dataware one
already has all the information you have
you have the dependency graph of the
compute
you have data aware edges in the graph
so actually with
very little additional information we
can compute reliable asset lineage um
and so it's like and you you don't have
to
integrate an entire other system just to
get that capability going
um it also enables really interesting
operational use cases
so for example um
you know imagine that you find some
table
in snowflake uh or
a file on a data lake and it looks weird
you don't know what it is etc
um and if you want to figure out how to
debug that thing or find the person
responsible for it you can just go to
our tool
and we have a well-formed index and if
that
asset had been produced by a dexter
pipeline
you can just type in like stories the
table and immediately
at jumped immediately to it and then you
have a page that links the asset to the
computation so you have the history of
like when it was touch class
some longitudinal and we think this is a
much natural
more natural way to operate
an orchestrator because none of your
stakeholders care about your pipelines
no one cares it should be an
implementation detail from their
perspective
all they care about is the data assets
that they rely on
so by you know what we found is by
having this kind of different index into
the orchestrator
it actually opens up uh many more
stakeholders to use it much more
naturally so because the
because the orchestrator already has the
information and we think there's a lot
of interesting capabilities that you can
unlock by vertically integrating
an asset catalog uh with the
orchestrator we we build that in
and the users that adopt that derive
enormous value from it but we don't
we have no plans to kind of expand to
all the use cases that a fully dedicated
data catalog does which might like
scrape
existing data sets for schema
and be tracking like ad hoc use of data
sets and there's lots of and really
complicated ownership ontologies
um you know we don't anticipate going
into
that sort of thing anytime soon so we
view the operational asset catalog
very much as a complement to kind of
more full-fledged
um special purpose data catalogs
got it um it almost feels to me like
sort of based on the way you're talking
about the system and especially the way
the system is architected again
with these you know chains of functions
um that are all
sort of parameter aware um it almost
feels like
you're taking us down this road of the
dag itself as an application
um like what what are your thoughts on
that
yeah i mean that's how we think of it um
and
that's how we you know we kind of you
know
um you know an initial phrase we use was
data application where
you know we kind of define these graphs
as data application i think this is a
big mental shift in the
in the system is that typically in
traditional workflow engines and
orchestrators
kind of the orchestrators invoke scripts
and the scripts are the thing that
developers operate on
uh and then only very important this is
an airflow
this is sorry this is like an airflow
paradigm right like exactly um
exactly yeah which is basically a sort
of a
step up from actually like crowning bash
bash scripts like
um presumably teams used to do in in the
good old days right
totally yeah how i like to describe the
old world based on that factory analogy
is imagine a factory but all the people
in the factory were blindfolded
and then just at a certain time of day
they would have to blindly look
to get the thing that came out of the
previous machine and put it through the
machine and then you just
hope that the right thing is there which
is literally how it used to work
um and yeah so airflow and other systems
like that were a huge advance over that
um and really important but you know
when you look at a a lot of companies
they might have an airflow installation
with
you know thousands of dags and they
might each have hundreds of thousands of
tasks and
the notion of kind of not treating those
artifacts as full applications
themselves i think is a huge
reason why you know these systems often
like collapse under the weight of their
own complexity and become
you know very almost like terrifying to
change
because there's no good local
development life cycle and no way to do
kind of integration tests in a
in a safe way um and therefore
you know you're just people are just
terrified of changing things so
if you instead view the graph as an
application that you've been able to
decompose
test and isolated components be able to
execute arbitrary subsets of those
graphs
and subject to a full developer life
cycle kind of be able to refactor it
in a way that's much more similar to
reactant refactoring
uh traditional code all these things
combine
to make it so that you can just manage
the complexity of these things much more
readily
um and kind of apply more traditional
software engineering tools
and processes to the bags themselves um
which we think is critically important
yep yeah that's really cool
um i love the thinking behind that um
so you know so so sort of away from some
of the
design architecture and the thinking
behind the system
um maybe taking a little bit more
practically um
at what time does a team gradu graduate
up to dexter like what's happening
in their in their data platform what's
breaking what's the pain point
um you know sort of what what metrics
are increasing that they don't want to
increase
um or or whatever like what are the
signs that
a team is ready for dexter yeah
so i there's kind of three i'll go
through three kind of typical times
that we've been hearing about a lot um
one is what i'll call the modern data
stack persona
so it's someone who set up what is
currently kind of being called the
modern data stack
and that would consist of an ingest tool
like five trend or stitch
they ingest that onto a cloud data
warehouse like big query or snowflake
then you might use dbt to do all your
sql transformations within the data
warehouse
then have a modern bi tool like mode
pull data out of that data warehouse for
dashboards and analytics use cases and
maybe uh
you know operational analytics or
reverse etl tool
uh census or high touch which can jam
the data warehouse
uh data back into other application
systems of record
and you get quite a ways with that but
there's definitely a hard stop
you reach if you try to do anything
that's outside of a fairly narrowly
prescribed set of use cases there you
know effectively the moment that you
um one is that the tools themselves
actually need to be operationally
hardened a little bit
and in that in that world right where
you have like both say census and five
trend and dbt running you actually are
back in a world where you have three
interleaved crime jobs again you've kind
of like gone back in time
so you generally need an orchestrator
there and then if you do something like
try to like
incorporate uh a team that wants to
build say python based data pipelines
into that world now they're totally like
they
you have to bring in a new tool to
support that so
you know i was i was talking to one of
our users
and he said you know yeah you bring in
dagster when you want to make the modern
data stack of modern data platform
was kind of the way he phrased it i was
like wow do you want to join
our company as a product marketer
because that was great uh
and uh so that's one case another
typical time is this green field
where especially teams that are doing
pure python paste
pure python based data processing saying
like pandas
typically an ml like panda scikit-learn
pi spark
um and they just like are very attracted
to the programming model
and adopted straight away i think and
then another case
is where you know someone has reached
the limits
of the um reach the limits
of the complexity that can be handled by
a traditional workflow manager
and the whole notion that the
dag itself should be subject to a fast
development life cycle that just
clicks with them um so
you know for example we work with
mapbox and they were in particularly
attracted to
the local development programming model
aspects of it because they were actually
spending something on the order of
50 of their compute budget actually on r
d not their prod stuff because
they couldn't really parameterize the
environment and program flexibly so they
could
operate in two different contexts and
they used dagster
to enable local development workflow
which reduced their spend so much that
their manager called them up
and made sure that the system was still
working but they're like no we just were
using this
you know new programming model which
allowed us to kind of
run on smaller data sets and run on
different compute
substrate uh which dramatically reduced
their r d
cost uh and then so that's another
example they also kind of
felt that dexter was a great way to more
manage the complexity
of of their dags because the functional
programming model made sense to them and
other issues
so um and what's some typical use cases
yep that makes sense um what's the lift
like for a team
to start using dexter i mean i look at
the documentation and it's um
to me it's deceptively simple um
you know for sort of the the power that
um is belied and sort of under the
covers
of the system um it seems like a
very straightforward programming model
um
what are the sort of the real world
gotchas if there are any in teams like
actually
getting on the system and getting up and
running like what's the what's the
minimum viable
um install of dexter that you've seen
i'm just curious as to like how a team
actually
you know gets on board and what that
looks like
yeah so you know and it's uh
ever-present battle that we continue to
work on
but we really strive to
really embrace the what we call the
progressive disclosure of complexity
um where you can
simple things are simple but complex
things are possible and the system kind
of
grows with you um the other term i heard
this is just in time complexity
where like you the user is learning the
system
and then they have some problem that
they've run into and then all of a
sudden you kind of like present them the
next thing that solves that problem um
rather than like overwhelming them now i
actually i appreciate the compliment
pete about the system but i still think
we don't
hit the mark we need to hit with in
terms of progressive disclosure
complexity and we're
we are uh we are actively working on
that um
which i'm actually there's a ton of
great work going on team which i'm
really excited about
um but yeah getting started is quite
simple you know if you want to just
going from zero to viewing a pipeline
in our ui is on the order of like a
two minute process um you can
write about six lines of python pip
installs two tools
type daggett which is our graphical tool
and you know you're off to the races
with this kind of
very lightweight graphical environment
so you can get going
um yeah and then you like typically the
onboarding process is you
you're playing around with running the
pipelines in an ad hoc way on your
computer writing some test cases around
that
then you think about productionizing it
and there's kind of a you know
we're invite we're infrastructure
neutral technology
so we have like for example a prefab
kubernetes deployment
but you don't require kubernetes you can
deploy it to your own infrastructure so
okay for some of our users deploying it
to their infrastructure it takes quite a
bit of work to figure that out
um which is another thing we're working
on um
but yeah you know we like we're big
believers in just like
you know making it seem kind of like
learn one additional thing at a time
and kind of build up comfort with it and
immediately get that feedback so you
understand what's going on
might have lost oh okay i think i lost
you there we go about
20. for a second yeah
um yeah so uh you were talking about the
i think the implementation or the the
deployment
um some of the deployment options around
kubernetes et cetera when i lost you
right yeah what i'm saying is that you
know we
it's primarily a software abstraction um
and we don't believe in say vertically
integrating with something like
kubernetes can not everyone use
kubernetes but
it should be easy to use on kubernetes
so you know
once you want to deploy this to prod if
you're using kind of a well-known
standard like
standard like well-known standard like
kubernetes you can
we have a helm chart for it that's very
configurable and you can deploy to your
infrastructure but
yeah you can also deploy it to your own
custom infrastructure if you don't use
something like kubernetes
so we support ecs for example
so yeah we strive to be environment
neutral as much as possible
and so that no matter what
infrastructure people are using people
can still
get value out of the tools and the api
so you wouldn't say so you wouldn't say
that there's any sort of minimum
team size um sort of required
really to to get up and running quickly
and make
make use of um of dexter
no it's a technology with a wide dynamic
range
you know to me like the idea that
there's a minimum team side for
structuring your computation into graphs
is like saying like
like there's a minimum team size for
using classes
in a programming language it's just like
it's such a fundamental way of
structuring compute that it makes sense
all the way from so-called single-player
mode all the way
to uh you know massive multi-headed
scale
um so you know like even
you know so yeah and by the nature of
the system
and the fact that we so focused on local
dev and testability
we kind of got all this single player
stuff
for free almost because just by nature
if you're enabling a test and dev life
cycle
in the context of a more like so-called
production grade system you kind of
also capture just a one person being
able to do interesting work on their own
um so you know again we've used
primarily as a software abstraction and
one of the cool things about software
extractions is that they have like
effectively infinite that
infinitely dynamic range like one person
can use it
it allows them to think about things
more clearly
um all the way to teams using it to
structure the relationships between
teams and whatnot
um and uh so yeah no it's a
you know um yeah
i think you should start using these
from from square one where you're
developing data products
yeah well i love how you think about
leverage you know it's really obvious
um in hearing you talk and and how the
system has been designed that it's
of prime importance to you because
that's that's the whole game
that you're in and so it's it's nice to
hear that so clearly
um what are some what are some of the
more advanced features or power user
features of dexter that you're excited
about um
i don't know if there's anything new to
preview for the community
um just sort of features that you think
are maybe underused in general and
should get more attention
yeah i mean i think the uh the one that
comes to mind
is you know i am super excited about
the fully integrated asset catalog and a
number of dimensions
uh i talked about um being able to view
longitudinal information about an asset
meaning like how long it took to compute
over time and
how many rows are in and things like
that um
and then also the integrated asset
lineage i think
is just incredibly powerful um
because um and you know the other thing
i think that's really exciting about the
way we structure
asset lineage is that we capture
this immutable record of all the
mutations or what we call
materializations of an asset over time
and that will allow us to do
um really interesting visualizations and
searching
because acceleration is a very
challenging
problem often because of this time
aspect where it's like
okay yes this this asset now depends on
this upstream thing but in the past it
did not
and i want to be able to inspect that
and be on the model that's super
important
and being you know so that's natural uh
you know we'll be doubling down on more
things related to assets as well
like for example um you know the the
term data mesh is very much
uh in the error and there's a lot of
stuff incorporated into that term
and you know it's like one of these
buzzy terms it means different things
different people but there's this
incredibly important idea
within the data mesh which i think is
the most powerful one which is that
assets meaning like data sets machine
learning model the produced assets of a
team
should be the interface with other teams
um
so instead of having and you know if you
depend on a team
in uh in like airflow or traditional
workflow
orchestrator you either have to put
everything into one like
mega dag uh which many teams do and
that's very difficult to scale his
number through problems
or you have separate dags and you're
back in a world where the dependencies
are not encoded
and so you're kind of like you know why
are you using this thing and
you know with it with a with a with an
integrated asset catalog we can make
assets
in the system the interface between
teams and potentially be able to
visualize
that i think it's an incredibly exciting
direction um
and that means that teams don't know no
longer have to integrate their pipelines
they just agree on that oh okay our
our unit of interchange is this table
here
and when you update this table we can
decide whether or not we want to
instigate a computation again and this
sort of like structured
but more loosely coupled dependency um
i think is a really compelling way to
structure data platform
and is the opportunity for the first
time ever to really
capture the structure of a multi-team
data platform in a manageable way in one
tool
so i'm super excited about that
direction um
yeah that's really neat so that's you're
talking about
um integration across
teams and when would i guess
both teams presumably using dagster or
there'd be other sort of integration
supported so i mean you can you know our
we have first class sensors
um which essentially means like
event-based schedules
um so you could potentially you know
you can eventually just events on like
every time this s3 file gets updated
um you know the then run this thing
but if both sides of the equation are
using dagster
and we know that this this thing we know
in a very verifiable way that this thing
creates an entry in our asset catalog
and we know that this other one is
listening for updates to that entering
the asset catalog we can do much more
for the user in terms of visualizing and
structuring those relationships
rather than just like kind of sensors
that we don't know what they do
um so you know
the system is flexible and incrementally
adoptable so you can
you can launch computations based on any
external event in the universe
but uh you know having we think this
integrated asset catalog
combined with the event-based
computations is a really exciting
direction to go
yeah for for formally capturing those
relationships
because then like those two teams they
don't have to deploy
on a synchronous schedule they could
even use different versions of python
they can use their own dependencies um
they don't even have to know the names
of each other's pipelines they just
agree
on a single asset key as their
as their unit of interchange and then we
can also surface that information in
very different ways
um throughout the system so it's uh
really exciting
yeah that's very neat um well i want to
zoom out just
just for a minute and sort of get your
thoughts on the broader ecosystem
because
i i know that you who are really
convicted about
the orchestrator being this amazing
point of leverage across
um data systems um teams
tooling etc you've called the
orchestrator i think in the past the the
town square um if i'm not mistaken
i have used that line yes
um so i'm curious like what's your
philosophy on
integrating with the other tools in the
ecosystem
like how do you think about that i'm
sure that's
front of mind for you sort of you know
because orchestrator
is at the middle um you have a pretty
powerful role to play in
how the rest of the town sort of
aggregates around the square like what
what are your what's your philosophy
there yeah i mean
the i think the the orchestrator needs
to
you know be able to in like in terms of
where business logic is encoded for
example
whether it's in spark or a sql query or
a python
you know a piece of python compute that
the orchestrator needs to integrate with
any tool and any runtime in that way
so you know the town square analogy
is or like the factory analogy is good
because you can imagine the different
types of people but they bring their own
tools to that central location
you can't exclude anyone because they're
using a different tool
i think the other thing is that
you know all the other kind of
uh many of the other uh uh
tools that are not just like what where
you encode your business logic so like
for example say a data quality tool
um the data quality tool has to play
with the orchestrator
to some degree somewhere because who
decides when the data quality test gets
run
right that is the orchestrator so it
makes sense for the orchestrator to be
aware
of that concept to some degree but then
to be able to invoke
external tools that implement that
concept
and so that's really the way we think
about it we want to be
somewhat opinionated about process
and the way that you structure pipelines
but as neutral as possible
into the actual implementation of
different tools that you use
in the process of building that pipeline
um
yeah yep got it
um and another sort of high level
question nick because you've
you know spent spent so much time um
building developer tooling and
i think the community appreciates your
thoughts um where do you get inspiration
you know as you think about system
design or
um abstractions um even language design
like where does that inspiration come
from from you i'm curious
oh god it's actually it's it's it's
difficult to answer
because i'm so submerged and immersed in
the world and i'm like always listening
podcasts and youtube videos and reading
stuff
that um you know
the um that's difficult to isolate kind
of one spot
because it's kind of this continuous
process um which i guess is kind of a
cop-out answer
um but you know like
the i really appreciate like
for example for my time at developer
division i really look up to
for example like anders heilsberg who's
the designer of c sharp and now the
designer of typescript because i think
uh he does an amazing job
of having this vision and state in
his head about where he wants these
systems to be at the end of the day
but comes up with a very
one an incremental way to get there and
then two
webs of abstractions that stack onto
each other such that an individual one
is independently useful but the whole is
greater than the sum of their parts
um and so yeah i get inspiration
i get inspired from a lot of these
systems that embrace
these composability principles
that really respect both the problem
that's being solved and respect the fact
that developers
given kind of the proper framework are
actually
quite clever and are able to kind of
build the complexity and like give them
the space
to like innovate on top of your stuff
like to me
things are going right when people come
out of the woodwork and are
using using the tools that you're
building
in kind of novel ways that you wouldn't
have thought of so i really look
for systems that nail a use case but
also have kind of this
ability for people to innovate on top of
the platform
yeah for sure that's that's got to be
very rewarding to see
um well nick it's been great chatting um
i'm i'm really hoping and expecting that
folks will want to check out
dagster where can they find out more
information i think you have a vibrant
slot community um you know give us a
couple addresses and tell us where
people can
can find more about the the tool sure so
we're a github project
so you can google daxter github and look
at her look at her code and get clone it
um we have daxter io which contains our
docs
links to all the things i mentioned as
well as a link to our slack community
which is quite active
the team is always on there and very
responsive
they um are very dutiful and hard
working in that response and even i get
in there at some point when i have some
time i love
i love talking to users and seeing what
they're doing um
so those are the primary resources okay
great
awesome um and just as a final question
before i let you go
what surprised you most about your work
in the data ecosystem so far
what has surprised me the most that is a
great
question and
i guess as time goes on what surprises
me
is just how deep the rabbit hole goes so
to speak
in terms of the number of problems that
have to be solved
and it's it's self-evident in the number
of tools and companies that are popping
up
yeah like there's just clearly
you know all of a sudden you you know
you wake up one day and you hear about
not just a new company but an entire new
category someone's trying to develop
it's like oh you wake up and now there's
a metric store startup
and oh now there's reverse etl okay
that's
i guess that's a thing now so and it's
not like they're making up terms on
their own these are fundamentally novel
new things
so you know just like the the pace
of expansion and the amount of
opportunities but that also causes
confusion and complexity too which is a
whole other question but
yeah it's just like continuing to
surprise me the number of
problems that come up in the data
ecosystem and then
you know the um ingenuity of various
folks in the community to fill those
gaps and the pace is just
extraordinary well it is fertile ground
for
folks like you who want to solve that
complexity and
there are many many companies in the
data council ecosystem
who are continuing to pop up and and
we're excited to continue to support
them and support you
so nick this has been really fun and i
can't wait to see you in person it's
been too long
it has well thanks for joining us
thanks for having me um and thank you to
everyone
who attended today thanks for joining
the chat between nick and myself
as nick mentioned there's all kinds of
new stuff popping up in the data
ecosystem and
in two weeks we will have none other
than
tejas manahar from high to touch
here to talk about reverse etl so make
sure to
join us for our next episode stay safe
and be well everybody
look forward to seeing you soon